une attaque en cours en plein
ouagadougou burkina faso l'armée a été
prise pour cible par des dialyses deux
assauts menés simultanément dans la
capitale burkinabè cette nouvelle
attaque au burkina faso plusieurs
dizaines de personnes ont été tuées et
au moins 47 morts mercredi dont 30
civils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'observateurs qui ont fait le
parallèle avec l'ancien président blaise
compaoré qui d'après mes informations
avaient conclu un pacte de non-agression
avec les groupes terroristes de la zone
on a vu qu'il était très impliquée sur
le dossier manière parce que lorsqu'il y
avait des prises d'otages celui qui
intervenait ya des intermédiaires ou
parfois directement c'était tout
simplement une période pendant laquelle
il y avait un certain nombre de réseaux
du fonctionnaire en faveur de pouvoir
burkinabè et le groupe terroriste est
aussi très très concentré sur le fait de
vouloir
s'implanter davantage sur le territoire
malien
on peut dire que c'est un tournant dans
la mesure où
vraiment c'est phénomène est plus connu
au mali au burkina on se rappelle qu'il
ya eu neuf endroits du régime libyen le
pays à résister à cela en ce qui à une
occupation des régions du nord du mali
en 2012 le pays à résister à cela est
finalement à partir de 2015 on va voir
que la groupe terroriste de la zone et
prennent une certaine confiance d'aller
voir justement en dehors des frontières
maliennes c'est le début du
développement de la stratégie à leurs
niveaux autour de la zone appelée la
zone des trois frontières
deux grands groupes identifiés dans la
zone c'est le groupe de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans et l'état
islamique au gras ça nous avons un des
groupes non identifiés qui vont saisir
une opportunité une mauvaise note une
idée dans ce processus et a aussi
énormément de milices d'autodéfense qui
se sont développées dans la zone
notamment burkina faso le mal est
précisément le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
cartographie précise un concernant la
présence d'un groupe de manière sûre aux
un énorme problème aujourd'hui il est
très difficile de dire exactement qui
procède à ces actes
l'armée dans ces zones dans un
très en retard par rapport aux enjeux
parce que
quand on voit le cas du burkina les
enfants les responsables de l'armée
aurait changé récemment le président du
nom de son ministre de la défense aux
menaces de la sécurité donc ça entraîne
un problème d'instabilité chronique dans
les arbres pour désarmer en
reconstruction ensuite pendant le fait
qu' il n'y a pas de coalition digne de
ce nom le g5 sahel a été créé et a été
opérationnaliser à partir de 2017 on
voit que ce g5 scène à part quelques
opérations ici et là ne parvient pas à
être une force efficace tine de ce nom
donc l'armée est dans un état de
faiblesse très avancé il ne s'agit pas
simplement d'un problème de moyens est
un moustique il s'agit avant tout d'un
problème de formation de renforcement
des capacités et surtout de la
coordination d'abord entre les
différentes forces sur le territoire
national ensuite entre les forces
nationales et la force internationale et
ensuite en troisième bull entre les
militaires et les civils
donc on peut craindre le pire mais il va
être très difficile justement pour un
set groupe de prendre l'ensemble de la
zone parce que ce sont des zones très
vastes avec une population diverse avec
une idéologie parfois différente à
certains endroits et il ne faut pas
aussi oublier que cette europe là ne
sont pas de groupe uni il ya des
rivalités en leur sein et tout ce
processus par peut faire en sorte que ce
groupe là malgré leur volonté est pour
le pain à pouvoir occuper en tout cas de
manière certaine durable il un
territoire assez vaste dans cet
événement